what are they like your favorite games
oh gosh let me think
um i've got quite a few oh yeah for sure
you gotta gotta
love it yeah throw in the ball yeah the
three-pointer yeah
i love my football no let's see um
actually though i really
um i have a wide range of games that i
enjoy but right off the top of my head
some of my classic favorites i would
have to say one of my favorite games
ever is bloodborne
i love you hell yeah because let me tell
you something real quick
i suck [ __ ] at doom i get that but get
me into any souls game
we'll have some fun listen have you
streamed any yet
i i can't i can't fortunately but you
know maybe it
maybe someday working on it you could
say what will happen in the future
i really want to play uh bloodborne with
ina because she is uh familiar with the
cthulhu
stuff oh yeah yeah as you may know i
like bloodborne because it's the only
frost software game that i actually
could finish yeah like i've never been
able to finish a dark souls game
[Music]
uh skill at the games i would probably
say bloodborne is
the one that i can pretty easily do
after that dark souls a little more
difficult but
i can get through them yeah i've heard
bloodborne is like the more difficult
one i thought was easy it depends on
what play style i think you like yeah
because like dark souls what makes darks
also like tough for people is that it's
you really have to be patient like
bloodborne you can kind of just like
run in right and you're rewarded by
going in yeah exactly
yeah but with dark souls if you run in
you're immediately dead that's why i
like doom man you literally are just
rewarded for just being like a
just a monkey i didn't realize that
until i started playing it more and i
was like i see what kind of thing and
then
is like the combination of bloodborne
and dark souls right it requires the
patience of dark souls but
if you want to and you're skilled enough
you can just run it exactly
now they're on this topic i've got to
ask do you care about your stories in
your video games or do you skip all the
dialogues
are you just are you just a game player
gal it depends on the story to be honest
it takes
a lot to get me invested in a story it
has to be it has to have something
really special i think
otherwise um i'll skip everything if i
just enjoy
the gameplay it just it really depends
for example i really liked um
bloodborne's very subtle lore i would
say i enjoyed that aspect
by the way yeah yeah yeah i'm pretty
sure i i guess but um
i liked the the subtle storytelling it
just depends it is i guess
the the basic answer that i love the
game boots up right first cutscene plays
you'll always give the first cutscene a
chance
yeah yeah i would say i'm just
immediately skipped oh wow okay every
single time i'm like
i want to get in the damn game stop
[ __ ] making it okay
i see i see yeah and i'm like oh there's
an hour cut scene before i can play the
game [ __ ] brilliant
yeah i was going to get
a ps4 to get death stranding but when i
heard there was like a movie
at the end oh yeah yeah the final cut
scene i was like i'm okay i don't i mean
death stranding sounds like the worst
game you could possibly play because
even the gameplay
is not really gameplay yeah it's just
walking it's a walking simulator right
that's what i've heard that is the word
on the street i personally haven't
played it yet like
that's the only reason why like i love
my story based games don't get me wrong
like jrpgs i'm like [ __ ] all over
that [ __ ] but when i look at that the
last
cutscene for death training is two hours
yeah i was like i'm not like i can't
skip it i'm just like kojima white
i should have just made a movie like why
that's the thing death training isn't a
game it's just a movie with a game
attached to it
that's basically what it was because jim
is like i want to make a movie yeah
people like
no one's going to watch that's like but
what if i put a game in there
i think that when you find the balance
it's perfect for example the game that i
really want to play on stream but i
can't right now is ghost of tsushima oh
such a good game i [ __ ] love that
game it's so good i've never been
obsessed with the game
so long but that's like like that is the
perfect mix of
story and as beautiful gameplay
what it is but how it's portrayed in
ghost ashima dude i still really want to
go to tsushima yeah
yeah holy [ __ ] yeah i don't know like
i'm a pc gamer everything but console i
used to be like
addicted to xbox but then uh i just like
yeah you still don't own a
playstation dude no no which is i'll get
a ps5
i'll get a ps5 that's fine
i mean i like i have a switch that i
barely play right yeah
i i i like i bought like a lot of games
to switch that have just been unopened
really i'm gonna play that i'm a player
one day i'm gonna do it and i never do
because then i'm just like all right
boot up league of legends again and be
depressed for another hour
so so to contrast joey's virgin gamer
setup what is
what is what is your setup to when you
when you stream your games and stream
and be a youtuber i guess okay well
basically so so far um
here's basically how my journey has gone
with streaming games so
from the beginning out the gate um
despite having bought a quote-unquote
gamer laptop a quote a so-called
gamer laptop cringe down my spine right
yeah yeah yeah
that's what they call it right when you
when you stroll into the store and
you're like i need something kind of
high spec for what i want to do right
you walk in there like let me show you
and they take you over yeah exactly well
i needed something that would suit my
needs for uh for animating uh
for doing my animation freelance right
right um so i you know told them what i
needed and they said well how about this
gaming laptop and i said i kind of like
games
i kind of like it okay well i'll get to
right this and i can play games on it
and i can animate
so i i buy it um and then i realize
yeah i can i can kind of play games on
it at like a medium quality but can i
stream them oh [ __ ] no
oh i cannot do that um and i realized
very quickly that that wasn't going to
work especially for this line of work
right
so before that um i was just using
i guess what is a game capture device um
that i root to
my television screen and then i read it
into
the laptop and it's able to capture it
perfectly perfectly fine
though when i'm playing on my console
because obviously if i'm using a console
it's not as much of a problem
on my computer while i'm trying to
stream etc um
but i recently to fix that because of
course
playing doom on ps4 has been something
else
i tell you what with the ps4 it's just
been something else
um i decided you know we'd we'd try and
get like a
okay a new pc and and i received one i
received one i was very fortunate
and so i set it up and then i realized i
thought to myself okay great i can play
pc games
and then i set it up and i realized ah
my apartment is so small
i actually don't have any space for the
mouse or the keyboard so
my mouse set up my mouse is currently
sitting on top of the the what is it the
tower the rectangle the powerful
rectangle
that is i guess the computer yeah so my
mouse is on top of it
yeah my mouse is on top of it and i i
move it about two inches and i have to
pick it up and put it back and then move
it another two inches
to try and get to where i need to go the
mouse to where i need it to go across
four monitors right imagine imagine just
a crouched goblin
sitting on the floor with a chair on the
floor a desk on the floor
surrounded by four monitors with my
mouse on top of
the tower that is my computer you need
to get you a new cardboard box i think
yeah
you got right now well unfortunate
unfortunately you know when i try i try
to put the mouse somewhere else but then
i realize ah my bed is there
there's no room for anything well the
good news is though
um i i've already mentioned this before
on stream i'm moving
i'm moving so yeah so now the new place
is much bigger
new desk uh new setup i'm finally going
to be able to play pc games i'm very you
can finally get your game a chair
like a true game ago i was about to say
like the sims are probably hearing this
being like
don't worry queen we got it we got you
need
here comes the rainbow it's raining down